[Applause]
for
thank you very much thank you chairman
stefanuk de
Ruslan members of uh the house honorable
members of the Rada
excellencies it is such an
honor to address you in this house of of
Ukrainian
democracy as I stand in this Majestic
Hall my heart is full of
emotions
admiration for your courage and your
endurance
grief for all the suffering that Russia
has inflicted upon your Beloved
Country
respect for all the incredible
legislative work that this house has
carried forward even as you fight an
existential
War but the strongest of all feelings is
gratitude all of Europe owes you deep
gratitude for all what you have done
since the beginning of this brutal War
you are fighting not only for your
freedom and and your
democracy and your future but for ours
too you are fighting for
Europe this is something we are
painfully aware
of dear members of the Rada dear people
of
Ukraine
[Applause]
daku
on a wall of one of the parliament's
buildings there's a beautiful
mural by French alist chrisan
gami this mural reminds us of the deep
ties between the people of
Ukraine and the rest of
Europe but also of your
courage and your
determination the mural shows a hero of
Ukraine's
resistance Alexander
Mafi you all know his
story he was captured by Russians in the
Battle of
bahmut they made him dig his own
grave and they executed him in one of
too many war crimes of this bloody
war but Alexander looked at his
killers there was no fear in his
face he stood defiantly in front of
them and he said two simple
words words of
freedom words of pride
words that meant that Russia will never
win this
war and now these words are
forever etched on that wall and in the
hearts of all the free people of the
world glory to Ukraine Slava
[Applause]
Ukraine
Alexander mateski has become a national
hero because you all share his
spirit all ukrainians are standing up
against Russian
brutality and in front of your
bravery there's only one think that we
in the rest of Europe must do and that
is to stand alongside Ukraine for as
long as it
takes and this is why next week we are
announcing our 12th package of sanctions
against Russia the new sanction
shall include up to 100 New listed
individuals new Import and Export bans
actions to tighten the oil price
cap and tough measures on Third Country
Companies which circumvent the
sanctions for too long many in Europe
thought that we could trade with Russia
and integrate it into Europe security
order but it has not worked and it will
not work as long as Russia's action are
driven by delusional dreams of
Empire this is one crucial lesson that
you the people of Ukraine have taught us
throughout this
war so we shall not repeat the mistakes
of
2014 and we will continue to apply
maximum pressure against Russia until
the end of the aggression and until
Ukraine has reestablished a just and
Lasting
[Applause]
peace
indeed Europe is learning a lot from
Ukraine this is a message you do not
hear often
enough the people of Ukraine do not need
to learn how to be European you are
European
[Applause]
and when President zalinski addressed
the European Council last week he spoke
as a European
leader since the beginning of the war
Ukraine has proven so
much you are showing the power of
democracy you are showing the power of
in
genuity and you are showing the power of
European
values and these are the three main
topics that I would like to focus on
today and
here in front of the elected
representatives of the Ukrainian
people I can only start with the power
of
democracy I remember very well
when one year ago we presented the seven
necessary steps to accompany Ukrainian
candidate status on its way towards the
European
Union some said they were too
ambitious but your reaction was
extraordinary all your Democratic
institutions have mobilized at maximum
to fulfill the desire of the the
Ukrainian
people as president zilinski
said you did not ask for discounts or
shortcuts instead you have shown that
Ukrainian democracy can
deliver the breadth and the depth of the
reforms you have passed is amazing and
astonishing the Constitutional Justice
Reform
the selection of the High Council of
Justice the anti-corruption
program progress against money
laundering important measures to curb
the oligarchs grip on your public life
the New Media law and progress on
National
minorities we know that this has not
always been
easy but this is the normal path of any
democracy we
discuss we
disagree we discuss even harder then we
find
Solutions and then we
deliver and you have made great strides
much greater than anyone expected from a
country at
War you are undergoing deep reforms
while fighting a fullscale war
and the goal is truly Within
Reach continuing to strengthen even
further your anti-corruption
efforts passing the law on
lobbying strengthening the asset
declaration framework in two aspects and
addressing the remaining recommendation
of the Venice Commission on National
minorities including
education these are measures that are
necessary to fulfill
the complete seven steps and you can
make it and you can make it swiftly you
have already completed way over
90% And we will continue to provide all
the technical and political support you
need I am confident that you can reach
your ambitious goal and that
is for the historic decision to open the
process of accession negotiations to be
taken already this
[Applause]
year
honorable members dear
friends my second Point has to do with
the economy of this country and the
Ingenuity of the Ukrainian
people let me tell your story of a young
Ukrainian Talent called Valentine
fretka he was only 17 when he invented a
new technology to make paper from fallen
leaves together with a local
entrepreneur he launched a startup
called
relief they got in touch with cities
that were eager to get rid of tons of
fallen
leaves and they started producing paper
bags for
companies that were willing to go green
without cutting one single
tree and
then in
2021 you the frna Rada passed
legislation to ban plastic
bags in line with the European green
deal
and this has given a boost to businesses
like
relief now despite the war and thanks to
EU funding this promising Ukrainian
company is expanding and selling its
products all across Europe and this is
just a
snapshot of this country's immense
Talent you Ukraine is a nation of
innovators not only a country of big
farms and heavy Industries but of Bright
Young Minds who are already shaping
Ukraine's clean and digital
future yes Ukraine's financial needs are
staggering but so is Ukraine's economic
potential and Europe wants to invest in
you and this is why we have proposed the
Ukraine
facility an unprecedented 50 billion EUR
support plan for Ukraine's
economy it would be financed with grants
from the EU budget and Loans raised on
the capital
market and we are working to also make
use of the proceeds of the immobilized
Sovereign Russian assets the fa facility
will support Ukraine's recovery and
reconstruction over the next four years
and to put this into
perspective this would be more than any
European country received under the US
Marshall Plan that rebuilt Western
Europe after World War II and you
deserve it your country deserves
it
[Applause]
a critical task is
now to make the very best use of these
funds
and this is why we have developed
together the Ukraine
plan through this plan you can
reimagine the Ukraine of
tomorrow it is your
chance not only to rebuild but to recast
your economy through a coherent agenda
for reform and
investment you can shape a better future
and a better country for your young
Generations while continuing on your
path to the European
membership and the Ukraine plan will not
only drive Europe's
support it can also provide guidance and
coordination for international donors in
Ukraine's interest so it is up to you
now to show to the world our ambition
for the future of Ukraine
Ukraine honorable members people of
Ukraine two months
ago I decided to conclude my state of
the European Union
address with the words of Victoria
amelina Victoria amelina was a Ukrainian
writer a
mother and an activist for human
rights she was killed by Russia in a
massacre of
civilians in the city of
kator Victoria amalina believed that
this war has taught a lot to
ukrainians you have learned that you can
count on each
other and you have also
learned that you can count on your
fellow
Europeans today we
feel that we belong to one
family and one
home
because in the words of
Victoria home is where we trust each
other but this war has also taught a lot
to the rest of
Europe and the most important lesson of
all stands right right before our
eyes it is the power of this
flag the power of this flag our blue
flag with yellow
stars that you have decided to bring
here and I remember very well the
ceremony in the heart of the Ukrainian
democracy here in this
Hall perhaps too often we sometimes
forget what this flag stands for
it means
freedom and
democracy it means
peace and
prosperity it is a
symbol of ageold
values and it is a symbol of
Hope and you have reminded us of that
you are teaching to all of us the true
meaning of
Europe This is the spirit that leads me
here
today and like me all European leaders
who have come to Kei in over 600 days of
War we bring the solidarity of European
citizens but we do not bring Europe to
you because Europe is here already
[Applause]
ready
Europe is here in your fight for
Freedom Europe is here in your
Democratic
debates Europe is here in your
resistance against
tyranny Europe is in the eyes of all
ukrainians who fight for a better
future and together we can win this
fight together we can complete our
Union together we can bring Ukraine in
our common European
home this is the dream of Ukraine's
Heroes and Ukraine's
martys and it is our dream
too together we are Europe Long Live
Europe and Slava Ukraine thank you very
much thank
[Applause]
you
sh
[Applause]
f
back